your show f is for family I relate to it
because it's about parenting in the 70s
and that's you know that was when I was
parented like you what do you think of
parents now how do you compare them to
parents in the 70s oh that's just
completely the kids have so much power
it's like ridiculous like half of these
kids I'm like I look and I just have
what happened to me and I'm like looking
at a kid and be like this kid's about
ready to get punted across the grocery
store and it just never happens right
they just they just don't get hit and I
think it's hurting your mastery you're
wait a minute you're mad that children
are not being this should be the threat
of it half of it was just it look it was
just your dad was acting like he was
gonna do it he never did it but your
mother did because no cuz she was a
woman it was like okay cuz it's like
yeah you know you let a girl beat you if
you know you kind of felt emasculated
yeah we had a rule that like I actually
a lot of the stuff that I look at from
when I was a kid that actually kind of
made sense in a way is now would now be
considered like abuse I guess like when
I was a kid if you didn't finish your
supper as we called it supper yeah my
mother was just like well you're gonna
finish she would just wrap it in
cellophane and you just picked up where
you left off for breakfast like like a
blue-collar job like you take the shovel
out of the hole and just start digging
it again so yeah I remember one night we
had cube steaks which is like one of the
toughest pieces of meat I don't know if
you guys everything so like Asian
infused Wagyu beef everybody's eating
that crap now but cube steak was like
they had literally had to hit it with a
hammer to make it like edible and so we
were having cube steaks and I figured my
little brother was still in a highchair
and he couldn't finish his so my mother
goes are we just gonna feed it for
breakfast and that was like eight hours
away which was like half his life so the
next we remember we were having waffles
my mother always made Sunday breakfast
so we had all these waffles eggs bacon
this whole layout and my brother was
looking at half-eaten cube steaks and a
little mound of green bean casserole
and it goes so he looked at my mom he
goes mom kind of a waffle and she goes
no you got to finish your supper he's
like well after I finished my waffle a
supper then can I have a waffle she goes
no that is your breakfast and he goes oh
mom I hate you and my dad without
looking up took a full glass of milk and
through with this what kill you want
everyone today to have as miserable a
childhood is you know but it was kind of
funny we know it Solaris was my mother
just popped up and just immediately
started cleaning up and my dad just kept
eating like he didn't like I like the
rolls were defined back then now the guy
has to throw the milk he has to clean it
up while telling his wife she's brave
for just sitting there
so overrated right we went for a night
wait wait what wait wait wait we went
from not listening to them to now it's
just it's just you know it's just it's
it's ridiculous like that believe women
it's like all of them how about 85 per
side you eighty seven percent all right
but that last thirteen percent that keys
your car let's your [ __ ] on fire who
puts a family pet and up in a pot of
stew put a pot of stew Glenn Close
that's yeah okay all right I think it
was a separately you know I miss I miss
yeah tougher parenting in evidence those
are the things that I missed from my
childhood evidence yeah you mean if he
process right somebody says something
happen and then someone else goes well I
said it happened this way like the old
gumshoe shows then they had to figure it
out right yeah that doesn't exist no on
social media it's right well it's just
frontier justice right you feel how
nervous everybody just got in here at
the fact that I just suggested that
there should be due process this guy's
talking crazy man that he just join Isis
and the wounds that they have read but
they were they didn't agree when it
counted we cannot we'll digitally add
wounds don't worry we have the wound
machine you are way too angry 50 is
still relatively young you are the you
of the anger of a 110 year old man at
least telephone game
you